tirer ou pointer jeudi 1er novembre le
club de pétanque de plaisir organisait
son grand prix annuel
parmi les pétanqueurs un invité de
marque le tireur dylan rocher 20 ans
tout juste auréolée de son titre de
champion du monde senior décrocher
quelques jours plus tôt à marseille
il est à ce jour un des plus jeunes à
avoir porté ce titre
ben c'est sûr que je fais du monde voilà
ici on en a rien a chance de le gagner
on ne peut pas être plus ou quoi je
dirais puis bon surtout que ça s'est
passé à marseille avec 6000 spectateurs
voilà c'est avait une ambiance
particulière moi je me suis entraîné
tout petits avec mes frères mon père
voilà petit à petit j'étais dans une
école de pétanque puis après j'ai fait
deux trois compétitions avec mon père tu
vois là après si tu es parti quoi j'ai
fait les sélections en juniors pour
l'équipe de france j'ai été sectionnés
puis après j'ai été champion du monde ça
et puis bah pareil en seniors donc moi
c'est vrai que ça va vite quoi
de passage à plaisir où il a vécu trois
ans le jeune champion a profité du
tournoi pour revoir ses ennemis
prochain tournoi en vue le national de
caen et grenoble ce qu'on peut encore
lui souhaiter ba a essayé d'en avoir le
plus possible des titres de champion du
monde et puis au niveau des shows pead
france va essayer de ramener pas mal
quoi